E aí
olá olá
o baú eu tentei começar tento começa
fala
e tal qual foi descrita né de escrevendo
algumas coisas não tem uma fruta por
exemplo e come na frente de vocês
e se poderia descrever como é que essa
fruta para mim
é o verdadeiro sabor dela ser ela é
azedas ele é a Cida cheiro dela
que poderiam
e talvez mas eu diria que você não pode
você pode sentir o cheiro dela ver as
características ver como ela é imaginar
o gosto
as ruas
Oi e a partir daí você pode chamar noção
do que essa fruta só uma noção quem é
que você como essa fruta sempre tem um
pedaço da minha própria fruta ainda que
você coma fruta da mesma espécie ou a
mesma fruta ainda assim você não vai
poder saber todos os sentidos this
o que não é você que também gostando
dessa fruta uma você que tá sentindo
aquilo na sua boca
e esse foi vendo que eu usei Para Dizer
para vocês que é tal qual quando eu falo
e exemplifique situações de Deus o
Bíblia mesmo descrevendo em detalhes
a cada detalhe cruel e só sido você já
saberá o que eu descrevo vai imaginar o
crescer mais a mais e friso jamais vai
sentir da mesma forma
e isso me faz lembrar de quando eu era
criança
a equipe imaginava que todos éramos
iguais de maneira é Perez objetivo às
vezes e também fisicamente
em uma das situações e foi tomar banho
com a minha mãe e vendo que os nossos
genitais eram diferentes eu perguntei
para ela mãe que que é isso
e a minha mãe sendo que ela falou dos
pelos pubianos dela me disse quando tu
quiser tu vai ter também
a junta se essa história
o Max aqui é sempre na minha casa e ela
tem uma verruga no nariz essa vez não
foi autorizada e vez ou outra acabou
volta de umas das outras vezes e Samsung
com telefones está um pouquinho sangue
assim e eu fiz uma ligação direta já
entendi vai cair quando eu crescer tão
pobre lugar da minha filha
é a mesma de na Sarah muito esperta
conversa ela ainda continua assim
e eu fiquei esperando a minha vida toda
por isso quando que iria cair
eu nunca caiu
e essa não queda me fez feminino
importante um ser sofrem a partir
daquele momento é incrível pensar o
quanto imaginários sentido das palavras
pode e pode causar tanto transtorno a
palavra travesti por exemplo assustem
marginaliza de cara edital.pm tentar
substituir ela por outras palavras como
transpor exemplo uma das palavras querem
dizer a mesma coisa
é o sentido é o mesmo mas trânsito não
tenho peso moral da palavra travesti
travesti nos dá a realização de
internalizar quem somos mas os coloca no
lugar
o que sempre nos oportuniza financia o
direito de ir e vir pressão e quando eu
falo isso eu falo que eu lembro
exatamente do dia 31 de agosto 2015 se
era uma tarde de domingo ensolarada
então passeava pela cidade baixa o
bairro de Porto alegre feliz e realizada
por ter feito um Show lindo na loja dele
eu acordei tarde você procurar um lugar
para almoçar Sábado à tarde ela 16 horas
o senhor mesmo que aparentemente a 40
anos bem vestido como a mochila nas
costas discutir comigo do nada
e já contato com a discussão e aproxima
dele para repintar os xingamentos eu não
percebi que ele tirou delicadamente a
mochila e daí de dentro retirou uma
chave de fenda e me esfaqueou pelas
costas sem eu ter feito absolutamente
nada mais nada foi o que todo mundo fez
ali na vó ninguém a culpa por ser
saqueada foi minha Afinal as marginais
sempre soluções de tudo que ele disse
que ele falou muita coisa muito chegar
mesmo uma frase não saiu da minha cabeça
o teu lugar não é
quem sabe que tem razão meu lugar não
era assim mesmo meu lugar é falido por
outras e por muitas iguais a me ouvindo
discutindo oportunizando falas ações
concretas fazer com que as pessoas
conheçam e perco o medo e viram tenho
mais medo por coisa que nem conhece você
sai mais cedo e só ouviram falar pela
boca dos outros temos muito a dizer e
fazer Parem de acreditar em tudo que se
fala pela boca dos outros como se fossem
tudo um conto de fadas que elas não
existem fadas não existem descobri
acabar com essa visão de vocês
um abraço mano que não dá né mas abraço
e nem sabendo da saco não vamos
conseguir pagas
e se você acredita em fadas aliás
público não psicólogo fazer uma
atençãozinha
e vocês têm medo do que não conhece e
aquilo que erroneamente conhece eu faço
ter medo e ainda nem se permitem-nos
conhecer
nós não queremos invasões cerebrais o
Mudança de Comportamento Queremos ser
invisíveis temos a forma do tempo do
calor do pessoal do pão está fila longa
no supermercado
e ao contrário do que vocês pensam nós
não queremos destaque queremos o lugar
como estar aqui e ali juntar vocês aliás
queremos pelo vocês
o entendimento perguntando como sempre
faço
e quantas pessoas trans Você conhece
e quantas você já chegou aí na sua casa
Quantas vezes a teve desejo você já se
envolveu e não fizer Boa noite quanto
você já beijou quantas são suas melhores
amigas são amigas quando já passaram as
festas de fim de ano contigo quando você
já fez uma festa surpresa de aniversário
ganhou uma eu tenho resposta foi nenhuma
me compare com todas as suas relações e
se pergunte
se você não conhece porque tem medo
E ontem medo
um pequeno porte